حكمت المملكة العربية السعودية على مواطن أمريكي
بالسجن 16 عامًا وفعلت
ذلك بسبب تغريدات كتبها عندما
كان في الولايات المتحدة حيث يعيش
في فلوريدا ، كتب سعد إبراهيم أحمدي ، البالغ من العمر 72 عامًا ،
تغريدات انتقد فيها
الحكومة السعودية لسياساتها
الضريبية وأيضًا.  اقترح تسمية شارع على
اسم الصحفي الأمريكي جمال
خاشقجي الذي كان عضوًا بوحشية
قتل وتقطيع أوصال
بموافقة الحكومة السعودية
بعد حكم بالسجن لمدة 16 عامًا
يواجهه الآن أنه ممنوع
من مغادرة المملكة العربية السعودية
لمدة 16 عامًا أخرى.  سيكون عمر حمادي 104
عامًا قبل أن يتمكن من العودة إلى منزله في
فلوريدا.إبراهيم أفهم أن
وزارة الخارجية طلبت منك الإشارة إلى
هذا ، لكنهم طلبوا منك عدم قول
أي شيء كانوا يعملون عليه
وامتثلت لمدة 11 شهرًا كاملاً 11 شهرًا كاملًا
.  لقد عشنا هذا ، لقد
تحدثوا إليك حول كيفية معرفتهم بأن
والدك يتعرض للتعذيب ، لقد رأوا
تلك التغريدات التي كانت  عامة بشكل لا يصدق
وتم إرسالها من الولايات
المتحدة من فلوريدا وأنت
تتحدث الآن عما جعلك تقرر القيام
بذلك الآن
سؤال كبير آرون آه لقد كنت
أتبع إرشادات وزارة
الخارجية وسفارتنا في الرياض منذ
ديسمبر 2021 منذ  أنا أعلم عن
الموقف لأن عائلتي
أخفت القصة عني لمدة شهر أه
بمجرد أن أخبرتهم أنهم نصحواني
بالعمل معهم سراً حتى يتمكنوا من
الأداء بشكل أفضل ففعلت وبعد
ذلك كان والدي كامل ما  تم
احتجازه لمدة 11 شهرًا دون توجيه تهم إليه ،
والآن حُكم عليه لمدة 16 عامًا
وحتى الآن ليس لديهم نية
لوضعه في الحجز الخطأ إذا
كان والدي محتجزًا في روسيا أو إيران ،
فسنرى اسمه في العناوين الرئيسية كل
صباح
لا ولكن جوش من الواضح أن هذا في
سياق الولايات المتحدة التي من
الواضح أنها تكثف علاقتها
مرة أخرى مع المملكة العربية السعودية ومحمد بن
سلمان على حق ، حيث تفاوض محمد بن سلمان على
فريمان من هذين الاثنين.  مقاتلون أمريكيون
أه عون إنساني لأوكرانيا أه
لقاءات مع بايدن ويبدو
أن هذا هو الأولوية الآن
حسنًا إنه نوع من الوضع
الغريب حيث الحكومة الأمريكية سعيدة أه
المساومة للأمريكيين الذين تحتجزهم
أنظمة معادية لكنهم لن يساوموا
الأمريكيون تحت سيطرة الأنظمة التي يُفترض أنها متحالفة
، ونحن على يقين من أننا نتفهم أن
إدارة بايدن لها مصلحة في
الحفاظ على العلاقات السعودية الأمريكية
لطيفة وودودة وأنهم يحتاجون إلى النفط
ويحتاجون إلى العلاقات الجيدة ولكن في
نفس الوقت الأمريكيون محاصرون هناك
بشكل غير عادل وهذه مسؤوليتهم.
لإخراجهم وهم لا يفعلون ذلك
أجنبيًا